ونحييكم من جديد مع عوده الملف النووي الى
الصداره ومع تسريبات حول العثور على
يورانيوم ومخصه بدرجه تكفي للحصول على
سلاح النووي يلقي كتاب عنوانه الطموحات
الخفيه للقوه الكبرى للكاتب توماس
مدير المعهد الفرنسي لدراسه الدوليه
والباحث والاستراتيجيه والمعروف يلقي او
يشدد على ان ايران نهضت على المواجهه
الاساسيه مع الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
ومنذ العام
1979 خرجت من الحضن الامريكي لترتميه في
الحضن الصيني ولتتمكن من التاثير المباشر
على التوازنات الاقليميه فانها تستخدم
امكاناتها العسكريه والميليشاويه في اطار
استراتيجيه توسعيه وصولا الى ضفاف المتوسط
كما انها تطور برنامجا نوويا من اجل فرض
نفسها كقوه اقليميه وتحولها الى قلعه حصنه
كما سماها واكد الكاتب ان رئيس الا يراني
الحالي ابراهيم رئيسي بعكس عدد من الذين
سبقوه لا يرى حاجه الى انخراط ايران في
الاقتصاد المعاون بل يفضل ان تفرض نفسها
على محيطها الاقليمي من خلال تصاعدي
تاثيرها على بلدان مثل العراق وسوريا
ولبنان واليمن الامر الذي يعد افضل وسيله
لتعزيز الحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
نناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بيروت
مصطفى فحص الكاتب الصحفي اهلا بكم من
باريس مصطفى توصل الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اهلا بكم ضيوف يسمحولي ان ابدا من بيروت
معك سيد مصطفى في الواقع هذا الكتاب يطرح
المعنون طموحات الخفيه للقوه الكبرى هو
يتحدث عن اكثر من دوله وفي جزء من هذا
الكتاب يتحدث عن ايران فيطرح فكره الى اي
مدى ايران بين معادله الاتفاق النووي
والتوسع هي قادره ان ترتب اولوياتها حضرتك
هل ترى بان
استراتيجياتها التوسعيه مقابل اتفاق نووي
قد يريح من العقوبات كيف تفكر او كيف يفكر
نظام الايراني
مساء الخير هو السؤال الذي اطرح نفسك على
السؤال التي
على سؤالك هو اي اتفاق نووي واي نفوذ
ايراني
ايران دستوريا كعقائديا من دون تصدير
الثوره اي الثوريه المستمره للنظام
الايراني
يتعطل النظام تتعطل طبيعه النظام من دون
مشروع نووي
يشعر النظام بتهدد بتهديد لسلمات لسلامته
لذلك لا يمكن الفصل بين الاثنين ولا يمكن
اعطاء نموذج
دعينا نقول وسط ما بين الاثنين النفود
نفود النفود في العقليه الايرانيه هو
هيمنه باتجاه شرق المتوسط كما قال الكاتب
بغطاء جيو عقائدي بغطاء مصلحي ولكنه عمليا
عقده ايران في الوصول الى المياه الدافئه
وهي المعركه خارج لحمايه الداخل في
الاثناء المرشد المؤسس السيد الخميني كانت
قوه النظام نابعه من تضامن شعبي وهيكل في
النظام في بنيه النظام في الجمهوريه
الثانيه او المرشد الثاني كانت اتضحت
صعوبات النظام في التاقلم مع الداخل ومع
المجتمع الدولي او المحيط المجاور لذلك
لجا الى عمليتين نقل
الدوري الايراني في الخارج الى مرحله نفوذ
وهيمنه والداخل في حمايته
ذهب الى نموذج كوريا الشماليه مع الرئيس
الثاني كيم جينغ ان القوه النوويه هي
الكفيله بحمايه وبقاء النظام لذلك الاثنان
مرتبطان القنبله النوويه بمعناها التقليد
او القنبله الواحده هي حمايه لعدم اسقاط
النظام لا من الداخل ولا من الخارج لان
الترتيبات الوضع النووي تختلف ما بين دوله
واخرى والم الدولي ينظر الى خطورته ان كان
سيتدخل بالمباشره او من الداخل والنفوذ
بدا يصبح مدعوما بقنبله نوويه او مشروع
نووي معترف به كما جاءت فاجعه اوباما ب
2015 عندما فكر فقط في احتواء زمني
للمشروع النووي الايراني وغض الطرف عن
النفوذ الايراني والمشاريع الاستراتيجيه
او القوى الاستراتيجيه الايرانيه
بالمسيرات
بالصواريخ
هذه الصواريخ ولكن حضرتك في كل الحالات
سيد مصطفى تعتقد بانه النظام الايراني
يفكر بطريقه بين التوسع الاستراتيجي وبين
حصوله على هذه القنبله النوويه بغض النظر
عن اتفاق يعاد احياء واتفاق جديد فيه ملحق
ليس فيها ملحق
ولكن كيف ترتب ايران هذا الموضوع يعني
استاذ مصطفى طوسى اليوم مثلا في هذا
الكتاب تحدث او استند الكاتب الى تصريح
للرئيس ابراهيم رئيسي يقول فيه بانه ليست
بتلك الاهميه ان تكون ايران موجوده على
ساحه او على طاوله الاقتصاد المعاولم
فالبعض فكر في رفع العقوبات وكانه يقول
لسنا مهتمون باتفاق نووي حتى ترفع
العقوبات لانه لسنا معنيون بهذا الاقتصاد
المعلم حضرتك كيف تقرا هذا التصريح
نعم هذا التصريح لابراهيم رئيسي هو يسجل
بطريقه واضحه فشل النظام العقوبات التي
الذي فرض على ايران بعد خروج الولايات
المتحده من هذا الاتفاق عام 2015 كانت
هناك عقيده امريكيه ترامبيه تعتقد بانه
اذا مارست المجموعه الدوليه اقصى العقوبات
الاقتصاديه على ايران فان ذلك قد يتسبب في
تزعزع داخلي في خروج الايرانيين الى
التظاهر وفي سقوط النظام الايراني جراء
هذه العقوبات الاقتصاديه القصوى وبعد مرور
هذه السنوات راينا بان ايران لم تسقط وان
الاقتصاد الايراني لم ينهار وان النظام
الايراني يعني لم يعني تعامل بطريقه او
باخرى مع هذه العقوبات واستطاع ان يخرج
نفسه من عنق الزجاجه لذلك نحن الان امام
هذه الفجوه التي
تتبعها ايران عدم الدخول في نظام العولمه
اذا عدم يعني التعامل مع هذا النظام
العقابي الدولي لذلك هناك قناعه في يعني
في البلدان الاوروبيه بان ايران حاليا
يعني منذ ان خرجت الولايات المتحده من هذا
الاتفاق هي لا تريد بطريقه باخرى العوده
لهذا الاتفاق لان ذلك قد يمنعها فعليا
وبطريقه ملموسه من الحصول على السلاح
النووي هي فقط تريد وتتبنى استراتيجيه كسب
الوقت واستراتيجيه المراوغه لكي تحصل على
ما تريد في اقرب وقت لان امامها
نموذجين مهمين في العلاقات الدوليه
النموذج
كوريا الشماليه التي تقول بانها لان لديها
السلاح النووي فان لا احد صراحه يتجرا على
مهاجمتها والنموذج الاوكراني لانها لانه
اوكرانيا تخلت في وقت من الاوقات عن
سلاحها النووي اصبحت بين قوسين لقمه سائغه
والسبع والسبحت من الروس ومن ثم هذه الحرب
الروسيه الاوكرانيه لذلك نحن الان امام
قناعه بان لا خيار اخر امام ايران الا
الحصول على هذا السلاح النووي وهذا يشكل
في حد ذاته تحدي كبير للمجموعه الدوليه
سواء الاوروبيه او الامريكيه هل سيتركون
ايران هذا هذا النظام الذي يعني يتهمونه
بكل
انواع الشر هل يتركونه يحصل على هذا
السلاح النووي ام في لحظه من اللحظات
الفاصله من تاريخ المعاصر سيتم هناك تدخل
عسكري او بطريقه لمنع ايران من الحصول على
هذا السلع السيد مصطفى من قال ان ايران لا
تملك سلاح نووي من تواصل الى هذه النتيجه
خاصه واننا اليوم بحسب ما ينشر بحسب
المعلن فلا نتحدث عن غير المعلم بحسب
المعلن الوكاله تقول بانها تمكنت من
الوصول الى نتيجه ان ايران تخص ب
لايرانيوم بما يزيد عن 80% وحضرتك تعرف
بانه 90 بالمئات تمكنها من الحصول على
قنبله نوويه السؤال مطروح باي ثمن قد
تتحصل على هذه القنبله ستفعل ماذا مستعده
لفعل ماذا وما الذي يؤكد لنا جميعا بانها
لا تملكها اساسا
ساجيب على سؤالك قبل ما اضع تفسيرات لجواب
الضيف من باريس
كنا نموذج الكوريا الشمالي لا يمكن ان
يطبق على ايران البنيه الاجتماعيه في
كوريا الشماليه بنيه معروفه ومفهومه في
التكوينها اما الايران فلا يوجد امه
مجموعه من الشعوب الايرانيه ايضا ايران
تعاني من فكره الحواف القوميه انها مجموعه
انها دوله مركز واطراف وهذا كل طرف في
ايران كل قوميه لها بعد حيوي في بلد اخر
وناشطه في البلد الاخر الاكراد البلوش
الاذريين
وحتى العرب نوعا ما لذلك الحواف القوميه
تؤثر على المركز ولا يمكن للنظام الايراني
حتى لو وصل الى القنبله النوويه وقال انا
لدي وهذا التجربه النوويه وسوف اغلق نفسك
كوريا الشماليه لا يستطيع ان يتحمل النظام
الايراني المجتمع الايراني غير قابل لهذا
الانغلاق الذي قد قد تمارسه السلطه ايضا
لماذا لماذا الان وصلنا الى ان فكره ايران
تمتلك القدره النوويه وان هناك معلومات عن
تقسيط تجاوزات
كمان الجواب لك ولضيفك العقوبات تعم لديها
اثار سريع ولكن ليس كما نتوقعه نحن في
المنطقه المنزعجين من الصراع التي تقود
ايران في المنطقه اليات المجتمع الدولي
بطيئه وفيها ممرات خاصه لايران عبر العراق
عبر ارمينيا عبر عبر تركيا بدا المجتمع
الدولي يغلقها لهذه الممرات
الاقتصاديه لكي يزيد الخناق على المجتمع
الانتفاضه في ايران انتفاضه الحجاب وحدها
كانت كفيله في فكفكه بنية الاجتماعيه
ولطبيعه النظام وايضا 2013 ليكون معلوما
لدى الجميع ان كل الاروقه الاجهزه
المخابرات العالميه وكل مراكز الدراسات
كانت تتوقع نهايه 2013
انتفاضه جوع في ايران الذي منع انتفاضه
هذه الجوع التواطؤ الامريكي مع تواطؤ
اداره اوباما مع مع اداره روحاني وبالوصول
2014 الى الاتفاق الاتفاق النووي الان هذا
مستحيل نظرا للصراع داخل الولايات المتحده
حول الملف الايراني ايران
ذهبت في هذه اللحظه الى فكره التلويح
بالنوع التلويح بالتجربه النوويه بالقدره
بالقدره الوصول الى التسعين لماذا وقف
التخصيب مقابل وقف الداخل اي ان ايران
مقتنعه ان ما يحدث في الداخل منذ سنه الى
الان ومع انتفاضه الحجاب ومع ازمه الحواف
القوميه هو بفعل خارجي اضافه الى ان هذا
النظام دخل ليس لم يدخل في شيخوخه مبكرا
دخل في هو هو هرم لدرجه غير قادر على
التعويض
قد ينقلب ضدها وهنا سؤال باختصار انت كرمت
هذا التلويح هل يمكن ان ياتي
معها في صالحها او ضدها كما ترى العين
الغربيه
هذا التلويح سياتي ضدها لان المجموعه
الدوليه وصلت الى قناعه بالاضافه الى
الحلفاء العرب الخليجيين واسرائيل وصلت
الى قناعه انه لا يمكن ان نتصور عالم فيه
ايران تملك السلاح النووي والا قد يكون
ذلك اشاره واضحه ومشجعه للسباق النووي
سباق التسلح النووي في المنطقه وهذه
المعادله لا تريدها لا الولايات المتحده
ولا الاتحاد الاوروبي
ستبدو المجموعه الدوليه كل الجهود ومن
بيروت مصطفى فحص كاتب الصحفي اعذروني على
المقاطعات شكرا جزيلا على الحضور السلام
عليكم